I never wanted to be a part of a crowd I
always wanted to be an individual I hate
me when everybody looked the same so it
was like it was corny to meet him like
to like something cuz somebody else like
this so I was like that guy that was
like if you like it I'm not gonna like
it
I stopped living according to what
people wanted me to do I started living
according to what actually made me happy
the drug dealer don't have to be nice
his work gotta be good and that applies
exactly in real business as long as your
work is good people will come need
motivation mancha top 10 with believe
nation
what's up believe nation it's heaven my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference in the world so let's get
your motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and
chewing today's lessons from a man who
went from growing up in Harlem sweeping
barbershop floors and selling newspapers
to becoming the man who helped launch
Kanye West and jay-z and one of the
wealthiest men in hip-hop
he's Damon Dash and here's my take on
his top ten rules a success vol 3 enjoy
okay let's kick it up with rule number
one stand out from the crowd at a young
age I remember didn't yell that in in
nursery school when I was four or five
and I felt this feeling of embarrassment
and at that moment I was able to
identify that feeling and I was like I
will never let myself feel embarrassed
again so from then on
nothing young in age yeah that I would
just you know I didn't like the feeling
like I felt funny I felt like I was
shrinking like you know what Fred
Flintstone gets yelled at and you should
get smaller yeah I didn't like anybody
making me feel smaller just put by the
energy of their voice so it was almost
like I put this repellent on where
nothing could embarrass me you know I'm
saying so I just never really cared and
I never wanted to be a part of a crowd I
always wanted to be an individual I hate
me when everybody looked the same so it
was like it was corny to me to like to
like something cause somebody else like
this so I was like that guy that was
like if you like it I'm not gonna like
it
you know I always wanted to be first
never be last I never wanted to like
follow a trend I've always wanted to
start it and I think that comes from the
Harlem swag and all that and that
confidence is what made me not really
care so when I would speak about things
that no one else was speaking about if I
was gonna do something that no one else
did I embrace that loneliness you know
because it meant I was doing something
right
where other people write and and as a
result of it because I would always give
100 fearlessly and stand behind my point
of view I always got the reception that
I thought that I deserved which was you
know being able to have the life that I
wanted rule number two take control
again recognize what really makes you
happy if you feel like you lose and you
lose it it doesn't matter what other
people feel so I know how it feels to be
perceived as winning and be feeling like
I'm losing I stopped living according to
what people wanted me to do I started
living according to what actually made
me happy like if you in a situation that
don't make no sense then get out of it
don't make it make sense
one plus one always equals two if you
not happy change your life rule number
three be independent you got a kid from
the streets coming up and they're trying
to make it incorporate but they don't
necessarily have
you're not gonna make it in corporate
right he's gonna create his own
corporate he's gonna have to buy things
like you did in the street like a
t-shirt right you're five dollars and go
sell it for 20 and the reason why I can
do a lot of it is cuz Internet you can
do it on is it on as a Instagram or on
is a website and that's it it's a flip
there's no difference the only
difference between corporate and
independence this corporate doesn't use
their own money it's always a fun
another fun and another fun that throws
into another fund then the person that
that that finds all that money gets a
fee and acts like it says you know I
mean you know the game that's corporate
yeah corporate is a facade but it's not
yours you can't give it to nobody if you
can't give it to your family you know
I'm saying yeah a true man wants to make
his life easier for his children not
himself right so I can just have a job
where I get fired or I dive I'm done my
kids don't get it I'm a hustler for
pinching hell not and the company sell I
don't get nothing
what you working for if it's not yours
how hard you gonna really work for it if
you don't owe me think about it you
working for a paycheck you're gonna do
at least amount of work as possible
unless you really believe there's a
future in it
that's why with everyone I work with and
you can ask anybody in it as soon as I
get it in I know that they got the
ideals and the principles if you help me
I'm gonna help you
my thing is I make people independent I
don't make them dependent so if you
notice all the people I put on they
still doing it so you've got jay-z you
got Kevin Hart you got Lee Daniels
you've got Rachel Roy I didn't teach
them how to be dependent on me
I taught them how to rob me I taught him
how to cut the connector basically I'm
the dumbest person in the world if I'm
corporate I teach you how to get it
without me and I'm getting paid to be
the middleman so once I teach you that
you don't need a middleman you get rid
of it I'm mad at you for that that's why
I told you because once I make your
dream come true I'm gonna make my own I
don't want to sit around in your pocket
all day rule number four work hard on
your craft fight
expect expect to be uncomfortable and if
you're not devoting between eight and
twelve hours a day on your craft then
you're not really trying to be a
professional like you got to realize you
trying to be competitive being a
professional means being the best in the
world that doesn't just come with skill
that comes with discipline
you know that means you have to have a
certain kind of work ethic that means
you're doing things that most won't
people really don't understand that like
they think they got skills so everything
is gonna come to them skill is that
actually like a curse I've seen people
with no skill that realize that and
understand that they have to work hard
to get this skill worked so hard that
they do better than the people that have
skill and that are arrogant and entitled
that feel that it should just come to
them and then they just become a waste
you know having potential is [ __ ] if
you don't realize it it becomes corny
like you're the cool guy when you have
potential but like ten years later if
you don't realize that they need a corny
guy you're not saying and I never want
to ever be that guy rule number five my
personal favorite leave your comfort
zone what does it truly mean to be
independent just to be able to do
whatever I want to do whenever I feel
like it you know I understand like I
couldn't imagine like that's why I hate
his school I just ain't on and I'm not
saying people shade school but I just
couldn't stand a teacher that I didn't
think was cool or smarter than me
telling me what to do and then I had to
sit there and listen but for anybody who
actually has that fear like that wakes
up and they deal with that fear and they
go into a job and they're in between
deciding if they're just gonna go out
and be independent or not like what are
your words for them I would say blindly
do it quit and figure it out the more
uncomfortable that makes me feel the
better cannot be great comfortable great
ever rule number six make good products
I don't believe I should have to be nice
to get somebody to give me something if
my product is good no matter how I act
you will pay for it
you know that's another principle that I
learned in the street when people want
their drugs they'll line up they'll get
told what to do they'll be yelled at
they'll be talked to get in the back of
the line I'm only taking 20s don't even
come in here with a dollar that kind of
thing
no one's nice today the drug dealer
don't have to be nice his work got to be
good and that applies exactly in real
business as long as your work as good
people will come when your work isn't
good drug to have gimmicks right so in
the streets you got two four five three
dollar bottles and chicken bags but
usually the works not good right so in
this world when you overcompensate when
you don't have good work you
overcompensate with the tension you
start to become like your sell celebrity
that's what you leverage so
now your game becomes going outside
being a slave to what everybody else
thinks
and that's another rhythm that I didn't
want to abide by as well like I wasn't
gonna be about that celebrity all I want
to do is be about good product good work
be respectful make an honest living and
work with honest people and all and the
Internet has made it really possible to
do that because again you can make your
product you could promote your product
you could sell your product you collect
the data and have that relationship
directly with your consumer rule number
seven be selfless you know one thing
Abbas has to realize is your job isn't
to take care of yourself your job to
take care of other people so that means
you have to completely be selfless if
you're selfish at all you're not a boss
if you don't have the ability to care
about other people before yourself
you're not a boss people practice being
bosses every day cuz they're parents you
know you care more about your child and
you care about yourself that's like your
business that's what the boss does you
know I've had to pay my staff before I
pay my own bills because they did the
work you're gonna say what I'm saying
that's what the boss does rule number
eight do it all so people who take the
leap and they make that first they take
that first passion and build a business
or they start something but they have
other talents or other disciplines that
they want to build things around how
have you managed to build multiple
companies or take that blueprint and
apply it to different areas and manage
that it's because I look at all the
little companies as marketing for one
company when I make a movie I got to
make the movie right so I got to do that
but also after I make the movie I got to
distribute the movie so I built the
platform like name their studios or
whatever app I'm a distributed you
understand then while you're watching
the movie like you gotta wear clothes I
wear clothes I like to make clothes I
have the ability to do it I was in the
fashion business still am so I make all
the clothes it's a commercial for the
clothes I like music but not in a
traditional sense I don't want to
monetize and then exploit artists but I
do have a deep catalogue of music that
I've made while I was just inspired in
the moment I could use the music in the
movie so now you can sell the music you
sell in the fashion people drink right
so why won't you drink to look at it I
make I make the liquor so then now you
can you know drink the liquor but I'm
just saying so everything you see I feel
like I want to make because I have the
ability to do it you know what I'm
saying so I do it so I basically
leverage the things that people pay for
that's what I use for marketing so I've
always looked at looking at rock with
look at state property when I have a
movie called state property then you got
clothing called state property you have
album called state property state
property did 20-something million and
closed that year just because of the
commercial that the movie presents why
would I pay somebody to do something I
could do myself like well I'm gonna pay
a bodyguard when I can fight rule number
nine architect your life the thing is
you got to think about your future at
all times what do you want to look like
in ten years what is your day one what
do you want your data look like
so at 35 I'm like at 45 I'm definitely
not gonna be trying to be getting up and
going to a office and running behind
artists I'd rather be sitting by the
pool yeah so then I started investing in
us that's called art detecting I started
it didn't take like overnight but I had
to know what I wanted and had to
visualize it to make it happy be able to
also work on me like I was sick of
investing in other people yeah making
money off other people making other
people's dreams come true and then it
has to be a beef when I don't feel like
hanging around on them yeah you know
what I'm saying I got to look like this
you know meals whatever we're fighting
for people that just you know the crazy
thing is the more you fight for people
the more people try to make it look like
you're fighting for the wrong reasons
and I don't care what people think so it
doesn't matter but if I'm gonna do all
that I was like if I'm gonna fight I'm
gonna do that for me
but I'm gonna do it for my family I'm
gonna do that for people that are gonna
give back see there's givers in this
world and these takers in this world so
when you get givers together it's just a
love fest you're gonna get a giver with
a taker
it's a lopsided relationship and usually
the taker always feels like they deserve
more and don't give gifts and stuff you
feel what I'm saying yeah so I've been
able to heart detect it down to back
like the kind of people I want around
the way I want the the bots you know get
but just the intent of the people have
you always created your 10-year vision
is that something neither you know it or
do it yeah oh it's always so you always
knew
you like crystallize in your mind like
exactly like where you were gonna be ten
years from where you were
yeah yeah that's cool you have any
tricks or tips that you can help you
have to again visualize what you want
yeah and work toward it if you don't
have a script it's kind of hard to shoot
the move yeah yeah and rule number 10
the last time before a very special
bonus clip is learn everything what I
try to do when I start companies is
learn every single job before we start
hiring so for example with named dance
studios I have to got boogie running
game to a studios and Raquel you know
editing and posting and doing the things
so that when they hire somebody don't
know what to tell them to do or don't
know how long it takes and they'll know
what that person's doing their job and
not some more just like I gotta work the
cash register first
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from Dame - and how to make it happen
that I think you're really gonna enjoy
but before that I want to know what did
you learn from Damon today what message
really struck a chord with you what
change you're gonna make in your life
your business as a result of watching
this video leave it in the comments when
you write it down you're much more
likely to actually follow through so put
it in the comments thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you I
hope it continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon
and enjoy the bonus clip
a lot of people see the idea of being
entrepreneurs or being our own bosses
are building their own empires this
thing that you know you need investments
you need all these people need that slip
flip right look if this sock costs five
dollars to make we sell it for $20 you
make $15 flip with rocking with you know
I was trying to keep with rocky for a
long time she's Spanish and you know
Puerto Rican girls they can't bring
black boys home old school you know I'm
saying right so it took a minute you
know saying well and she was throwing me
curveballs left and right and so one of
her curveballs was you know I see put
all these other people on you know I see
you make all these other people's dreams
come true but you like to make movies I
can't get with you unless you stand
behind what you love and I was like all
right you know I had to you know I mean
she called me out you know I'm saying so
it was like you know I can't have my
woman or girl I want to be my woman
calling me out but also it made perfect
sense it was true I was unconsciously
probably standing behind other people
instead of standing behind myself
all I do is get somebody and tell them
how to get it and you know make the
things that are wrong right but if I can
make the things that are wrong right for
somebody else why not sell me you know
understand like even down to the
diabetes I'm like yo yeah we do a whole
network on diabetes so something that's
usually considered a weakness I'd prefer
to turn it into a strength it's about me
okay what I'm saying if you tell
yourself a story
Tulsa what a wail out of a handcuffed
lightning though Thunder in jail now you
know I'm bad over the last week I
murdered a rock into the stone
hospitalized a brick I'm so mean I make
medicine sick the fundamental key to
success is it can take between 18 and
250 four days of taking action for a new
habit to stick I've created a new course
called 250 for confidence or every
single day for 250 for days I will be
sending you a video between 30 seconds
and 5 minutes long that you start your
morning with around making you feel
confident it's absolutely free check out
the link in the description below to get
access